I means lay your heart I'm Bret Baier
I'm Katie Pavlich and this is the Fox
News rundown
Friday March 27 2020
I'm Lisa Brady a united front against a
pandemic the nonstop national effort to
try to slow the spread of kovat 19 while
caring for the growing numbers of
patients the number one thing I worry
about is protecting our health care
workers because they're the heroes on
the frontlines and we want to make sure
they've got the equipment to protect
themselves I'm Chris foster not that
staying home during a pandemic isn't a
good idea but legally says Judge Andrew
Napolitano governors and mayor's don't
write laws legislatures do and therefore
when they issue a decree that shall not
do this it is a suggestion and an
intimidation and I'm guy Benson I've got
the final word on the Fox News rundown
[Music]
a not so distant future for America this
is a country that was built on getting
it done and our people want to go back
to work I'm hearing I'm hearing it loud
and clear from everybody during a White
House briefing Thursday evening
president Trump highlighting what he
told the nation's governors earlier that
new guidelines are in the works from
federal health officials allowing low
medium and high risk designations around
the country that could make it easier
for state and local officials to decide
when to ease restrictions on residents
but the president's also emphasizing he
doesn't mean a swift return to social
business as usual a lot of people
misinterpret when I say go back they're
going to be practicing as much as you
can social distancing and washing your
hands and not shaking hands and all of
the things that we talked about so much
his optimism echoed by Wall Street as a
record relief package in Congress
rallied the Dow right out of a bear
market but worldwide
Kovach 19 has reached a milestone over a
half million cases the u.s. taking the
lead in that johns-hopkins count
Thursday evening with more than 82,000
cases even as the nation bands together
to do battle we've made tremendous
progress thanks to the great work of the
folks at the CDC and the FDA over the
last two months Health and Human
Services Secretary Alex azar in terms of
testing over 430,000 tests have been
done just in the day before yesterday
65,000 tests done just in one day alone
this is giving us a much better picture
of where we stand in terms of the
disease spread obviously our focus right
now is on New York in particular New
York City and surrounding counties and
so we're surging personnel and equipment
material in there working
collaboratively with Governor Cuomo and
local health officials there to do that
and then supplies you know it's
important for folks to remember that
we're a private-sector economy here and
the medical/surgical pharmaceutical
supply industry in the United States is
a trillion dollar
we have a small strategic national
stockpile that buys about half a billion
dollars a year of product that could be
deployed in the event of a hurricane or
tornado but was never envisioned funded
intended to replace the trillion dollar
private sector so what we're doing now
the major priority right now is working
with the private sector industry to
spool up production to source material
from anywhere in the world and get that
available into the private sector and
surge it to the hotspots where its most
needed yeah and I think like you say
many people may not realize you know you
can't just say oh I need you know thirty
thousand ventilators and the federal
government can just hand it to you and
likewise while there are things that can
be done to sort of compel industries to
step up and make those things it just
isn't something that happens overnight
and I know the arguments been made in
the administration there's no reason to
compel private companies to do something
that's already being done when you have
the automakers shifting gears if you
will to make things like ventilators and
other companies stepping up to pivot and
make masks and sanitizer and things like
that but in terms of cooperation with
the states
I mean well things calm down on that
front a bit once FEMA deliveries and
once these extra amounts get to where
they're going what we have done in terms
of supplies we very early on got on this
because we've in January we started
working with the respirator makers those
are the n95 masks that you see hospital
workers use we very early on in January
started scaling up from the ability to
make 250 million of those in the United
States a year to be able to make six
hundred and forty million in the United
States that's why we've been able to
deliver tens of millions of additional
respirators into our stockpile in March
already which are supplies that we are
able to provide to New York and other
hotspots around the country because we
were on that early we also were able to
allow industrial n95
which are the ones that construction
workers and miners use to be certified
to use for healthcare workers and then
surgical masks those are the more the
flimsy gauze like masks that people
sometimes tie over their face we've
actually conducted work to show that
those can be used in most hospital
settings and those are much easier to
produce and we worked with great
American manufacturers like Hanes to
invent a cloth version of those surgical
masks that is washable and reusable and
that they can produce tens and tens of
millions of in fast order so we were on
this right away under the president's
direction we've been producing and as we
work with American manufacturers I'm
talking with them every day they're all
just stepping up to the plate during
Thursday's briefing the president's
coronavirus response coordinator dr.
deborah birx pushed back hard on some
reporting about shortages dire enough to
spur second thoughts about resuscitating
coronavirus patients to say that to the
american people to make the implication
that when they need a hospital bed it's
not going to be there or when they need
that ventilator it's not going to be
there
we don't have an evidence of that right
now and it's our job collectively to
assure the American people that it's our
collective job to make sure that doesn't
happen
she also cautions against models that
predict big percentages of the
population getting infected emphasizing
the importance of reality on the ground
instead but what about the president's
push to get America back to work
I asked secretary azar if there's any
exit strategy or if it's up to states
that have stay home orders in place well
it's important to remember in the US
system that we are locally led state
managed and federally supported and so
the local governments your mayor's your
County Commissioners and in some
respects your governor's gonna be making
the decisions about mandatory social
distinct distancing or community
mitigation what the president did with
his 15 days to control this to slow the
spread was provide guidance and
recommendations no mandates in there but
rather recommendations to communities
around the country as we
he come to the end of those 15 days the
president's public health advisors as
well as his economic advisors will be
looking at the data and advising him and
he'll be trying to wrestle with the very
tough balance between public health and
economics and by economics
I mean economic dislocation has its own
public health implications for people
unemployment economic distress all have
public health consequences also so
striking the right balance and it may
involve looking at community by
community that communities in a real hot
zone like New York City certain
community mitigation steps might be more
appropriate there than in a small town
in rural Montana say that hasn't had any
cases well speaking of his team we hear
a lot lately from doctor foul he and dr.
Burks but every time doctor foutch in
particular says something that may be
taken as contradicting or disagreeing
with something the president said you
know a lot of hay is made about it in
some circles
how is the morale on the team you guys
all getting along ok so everyone's
getting along ok listen we're in a
public health emergency of historic
proportions and that I think focuses
everybody on the mission this isn't
about egos it's not about territoriality
parochialism that that has no place here
right now it's about getting the job
done which is protecting the American
people that's what the president's asked
of all of us it's what all of us are
committed to I've seen I've seen nobody
who doesn't reflect that type of
attitude and teamwork we put our egos
aside and just get the job done many
people may have heard about you being a
former pharmaceutical executive but they
may not know that you spent years in the
department you now run Health and Human
Services both as a general counsel and a
deputy is not your first rodeo with a
major health crisis I know you were part
of the anthrax response in 2001 also the
SARS outbreak how does this compare to
those situations well your so thank you
for mentioning that and I've been around
this department now for 20 years I was a
key leader as we dealt with 9/11 anthrax
attacks smallpox preparedness SARS
monkey pox pandemic flu
Ebola I was actually one of the key
architects of the whole pandemic plan
and so this is exactly what in 2005 I
was one of the people most calling out
that we have to prepare for pandemic flu
and so for 15 years this nation has
actually had pandemic planning that's
exercised we have plans we have play
books that we use that's what we've been
working through a lot of that being
behind the scenes though from the public
perspective it may seem like things took
too long to really start responding and
get going I mean is this the crisis that
might spur some lasting fundamental
changes not just now in the moment but
you know differences in testing drug
supply chains for instance well the
American people should know that their
team under the president's leadership
was on this really on day one the minute
the Chinese let us know about this
happening even through those unofficial
channels that we've been on it we
developed diagnostic testing immediately
we started securing personal protective
equipment immediately we developed a
vaccine within three days of seeing the
Chinese genetic sequence that vaccine
entered human trials eight weeks from
its discovery which is historic speed
even with the high throughput diagnostic
testing so what we're now seeing the
fruits of which is four hundred and over
four hundred thirty thousand diagnostic
tests being completed already we've done
more in eight days than South created in
eight weeks the fruits of that are
within really month just a couple of
months of the discovery of this virus
normally that would have takes taken six
plus months for companies like lab core
quest to have had high throughput high
high speed testing in their workflow
developed and developed and ready for
validated and use for people so we're
moving at historic speeds in every
respect is there anything about this
whole situation that kind of keeps you
up at night is there one area where
you're really concerned about falling
short or wanting to do better well the
number one thing I worry about is
protecting our health care workers
because they're the heroes on the front
lines and we want to make sure they've
got the equipment to protect them
because they are going into harm's way
and so that's why the whole of
government whole of economy is focused
on producing additional equipment for
them to protect them and allocate
product places like New York that are in
the hot zone that need this right now
and there'll be other communities that
need it in the future so much of our
supply chain especially on the lower
tech items like personal protective
equipment we're bound up in China that's
going to be a lesson for the future is
that we cannot make ourselves dependent
on one country just because it's low
cost production because we're realizing
these medical supplies are actually
strategic national supplies and we might
have to pay more to make sure that we
have access to them in America lastly I
just wanted to give you a chance to
offer any message that you want to get
out to the American public to this sort
of lockdown and concerned semi lockdown
and concerned nation of ours I'd say two
messages one is continue to practice
social distancing and personal hygiene
look at the president's 15 days to slow
the spread common-sense guidelines for
how you and your personal life workplace
or school or community can behave to
protect yourself and your family that I
think is very empowering just to know
that you're not at the mercy of external
forces only there are things that you
actually can do that make you and your
family safer the second is keep hope and
understand there's light at the end of
this tunnel all diseases have a natural
progression
whether that's seasonality or just the
natural burn off of disease that happens
it will happen it's happening in other
countries so um just just just always
remember that they call it a curve for a
reason there's always a down slope of
the curve it will come we're not there
yet but it'll come Health and Human
Services Secretary Alex azar thanks for
coming on the run down sir my pleasure
good to be with you
[Music]
this is guy Benson with your Fox News
commentary
coming up millions of Americans are
being told to just stay home unless it's
absolutely necessary to help slow the
spread of coronavirus to protect each
other and to keep health care facilities
from becoming overwhelmed
New Jersey Governor Phil Murphy and
Chicago Mayor Lori Lightfoot warned we
will not take any non-compliant behavior
this isn't guidance this is an order
that's enforceable by law we're gonna
give you an admonition and if you don't
turn right away and head home
then you're gonna get a citation and if
worse yeah we will take you into custody
around the country there are dozens of
these warnings directives or at least
advisories from state county and local
governments the decrees issued by
various mayors and governors are strong
suggestions intimidations use of the
bully pulpit Fox News senior judicial
analyst Joe Janet Napolitano Governor
Andrew Cuomo here in New York is the is
the most effective at the use of the
bully pulpit but it's just a bully
pulpit for several reasons one governors
and mayor's don't write laws legislators
do and therefore when they issue a
decree that shalt not do this it is a
suggestion and intimidation and and a
good suggestion about how you should
behave but it cannot be backed up with
the force of law second some of the
decrees that they are issuing interfere
with what we call constitutional
liberties and fundamental liberties a
fundamental Liberty is a Liberty who
have even without the Constitution like
your right to worship or your right to
move from A to B these are rights that
are in the highest category of those
that the law protects and it requires
the government to jump through the the
most difficult hoops in order to
interfere with them what if police were
to do something like say just broaden
the definition of a subjective crime
like breach of peace could they use
something like that well they could use
it for an arrest I mean they could
arrest you for it's Bobby Kennedy once
said of of Jimmy Hoffa spitting on the
sidewalk they could arrest you for
almost anything there the real question
is will will it hold up
the purpose of the arrest is to
intimidate but they can't arrest unless
they intend to prosecute because if they
arrest and they don't prosecute then
it's a false arrest on there they're
exposed to to liability so they can't
state it differently they can't arrest
you for breaching the peace if you are
not breaching the peace if 50 people
gather in Central Park in New York City
and they're all more than six feet apart
they are not even violating any
provision that the of the governor or
the mayor's edicts and they are not
breaching the peace and they can't
legally be interfered with and the
public needs to know that what if
they're holding hands and playing
ring-around-the-rosie though is there a
legal case that is not a crime it is
dangerous behavior but it's not a crime
and and the police would use their
presence the moral suasion that comes
with the gun and the badge and the
uniform to break it up but are they
going to put them in handcuffs and take
them away absolutely not
you're a any type of a cleric performing
any type of religious ceremony and the
people and the police knock on your door
because they wonder how many people are
there don't answer unless they have a
warrant you don't even have to say hello
yeah there's a church one of those big
churches in Louisiana that's had
services the last couple of Sundays with
a thousand people each and I think
that's dangerous unless they're more
than six feet apart but it's not only
lawful it's expressly protected by the
Free Exercise Clause of the First
Amendment and the state is powerless
powerless to interfere with that now the
state often does a lot of things that it
is technically powerless to do and then
it ends up paying a price for it when
the crisis passes and the lawsuits start
the governor of Florida has I am certain
he can't order this but he has strongly
suggested that anybody coming to Florida
as a lot of people do from the New York
New Jersey Connecticut area once they
get to Florida its self quarantine for
14 days I'm sure that's not legally
enforceable but once again it's a bully
pulpit thing right and again I do not
blame them for using the bully pulpit so
I disagree with Governor Cuomo on
many many things he has done and said
his use of the bully pulpit is brilliant
and effective if that's what governor
DeSantis in Florida is intending to do
it's certainly within the bounds of the
law and the Constitution but if he
actually restrains people if you fly
from New York to Fort Lauderdale and
they won't let you leave the airport a
that interferes with Interstate Commerce
which would be a violation by the
governor or whoever put into effect of
this this edict and be ifs are restraint
on your ability to travel which you
can't do the only way they can
quarantine you without your consent is a
if you are actively contagious and B if
you refuse to restrain yourself so this
character in New Jersey who earlier this
week caught on a cashier at Wegmans in a
dispute over the price of a dozen eggs
you can't make this up and then after he
crossed out I said by the way I have
coronavirus so this caused a tremendous
disturbance people fled the police came
the guy got arrested the governor heard
about it
the governor ordered the prosecutors to
charge the start with making a
terroristic threat but the state
overreacted if he truly was contagious
well then he's committed a very serious
assault if it was not contagious he did
commit a simple assault and a simple
harassment here's another one the
Justice Department is proposing
suspending habeas corpus to delay court
proceedings during this national
emergency basically saying okay this
defendant can be tamed detained
indefinitely until we have declared this
is past knowing you you're very much
against this idea when Madison wrote the
Constitution the prohibition on
suspending habeas corpuses in the body
of the Constitution they didn't even
wait to put that into the into the Bill
of Rights that's because of the
tremendous abuse of it that had been
visited upon the colonists by the king
and his agents and in fact the right to
habeas corpus is guaranteed in the Magna
Carta a thousand years almost 800 years
earlier habeas corpus is the right to be
brought before a judge within a
reasonable period of the time of your
arrest and most parts of the United
States it's 24 hours in New York
the crowded conditions it's 48 if the
government could lock somebody up and
throw away the key
it could lock up anybody who wanted it
could lock up Nancy Pelosi Tucker
Carlson Judge Napolitano anybody that
Joe Biden anybody there's a critic of
the government the FBI would have carte
blanche to do that this happened twice
in American history once by Abraham
Lincoln during the Civil War and once by
the Bush administration and Congress
right after 9/11 both times the Supreme
Court invalidated it because that turns
us from a democracy into a tyranny we
have thousands of jail and prison
inmates being let go I don't know their
sentences are being commutative if
they're gonna be politely asked to
return while Elvis plays out now
obviously prisons and jails were a
breeding ground for during a pandemic
like this it's dangerous for the inmates
is dangerous for the staff it's hard to
manage what obligation the states and
the feds have and counties have here to
balance health and safety of the people
in its custody and and having justice be
done and having and serving the safety
of those on the outside this is a very
very difficult problem Chris because
most state courts are closed meaning if
a person has been sentenced to jail for
more than a year meaning they're in a
long-term facility they can't just be
sprung by the jailer or the prosecutor
who sent them there they would have to
be sprung by a judge for a judge to do
that the judge would need to know a lot
of information about the person's
background in order to evaluate whether
it is safe to release them I don't know
how they're doing that when the courts
are not sitting so you have the the
imprisoned person on one television
screen his lawyer on another television
screen the prosecutor on a third
television screen the judge on a fourth
television screen the judge with minimal
materials in front of him because he's
not in his courthouse where he has all
of those law clerks to get all these
documents for him like the record of the
person in the sentence and he's got to
make a quick decision as to whether or
not this person should go out it's a
very very difficult thing to do my
understanding is that the initial wave
of people being released are
elderly I don't like the word but for
personal reasons meeting over 65 and
nonviolent if you're over 65 an on file
you probably don't belong in jail anyway
but they're there presumably for a valid
reason that's the first wave of people
that are being released state and
federal beyond that I don't know where
it's going to go I will tell you this if
a person is exposed in a prison the
government has the duty to care for them
that means isolate them and get them the
appropriate medical treatment the large
large prisons do have hospitals and the
large city hospitals have prison wards
so there are places in which this can be
done Attorney General William bar one
more question since the DOJ was gonna go
after medical supply price gougers and
hoarders if you are have a big supply of
toilet paper in your house this is not
something you have to worry about but if
you are sitting on it on a warehouse
with masks surgical masks you will be
hearing a knock on your door can the
government step in by executive order
and suspend free market in a situation
like this I mean the suspension of the
free market the the the invalidation of
the laws and supply of supply and demand
is why we have a lot of the problems
that we do the free market would allow
prices to rise and fall depending upon
supply and demand so if you would you
rather have $10 pay $10 a roll for a
toilet paper or have no toilet paper if
you pay $10 a roll the seller and the
manufacturer will have an incentive and
the capital with which to make a lot
more rolls because they'll know that
demand is for is way up so not only does
price and demand assure no or ting it
assures that information gets back to
the seller and the manufacturer that
there is more of a demand for this stuff
and because they want to make profit
they will start making the stuff 24
hours a day can the government interfere
whether the government interferes with
it all the time and usually when it does
so it makes things worse Jen Napolitano
Fox News senior judicial analyst
answering a few
legal questions related to the pandemic
judge thanks a lot for coming on
always a pleasure Chris
it's the latest from fox news podcasts
to campaign with bread pair with updates
from reporters on the trail and in
studio experts prep keeps you informed
on the 2020 race go to fox news podcast
comm and download the campaign with bret
baier now subscribe to this podcast at
foxnews podcasts com now some good news
with Tanya J powers while many
businesses are closed and more people
are staying at home to curb the spread
of the coronavirus one New York City
restaurant is doing its part to help the
medical community Tara Lucci Aveeno is a
popular Italian restaurant in Manhattan
and like many places it's now only
serving its famous spaghetti al Pomodoro
and other dishes for takeout or delivery
but they're also collecting donations to
provide meals to healthcare workers at
the city's hospitals Luca di Pietro is
the owner and has launched a website
where people can donate and that's
already generated more than 450 meals
across several hospitals he enlisted the
help of his daughter and her classmate
after the two returned home when their
university suspended in-person classes
he says he's trying to help the medical
community and keep some of his staff
working he's already had to lay off some
workers the website feed the frontlines
allows people to donate meals starting
at $25 and it says it's raised more than
49 thousand of its goal which is a
hundred and forty thousand dollars if
you'd like to learn more about how to
donate go to feed the frontlines
NYC dot org Tonya J powers Fox News
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
guy Benson what's on your mind there's a
mom and pop restaurant right around the
corner from where we live my family eats
there once every week or two we know the
owners it's a great spot because of the
coronavirus crisis they've had to
effectively layoff 80% of their workers
people that we know the hope is to hire
them back one day once we're through
this but that seems to be a moving
target and question marks abound similar
scenes are playing out all across the
country there is of course a major role
for government intervention in a crisis
like this to help the American economy
where it's no business's fault it's a
global pandemic but we can also do a
small part as well we are ordering
takeout every few days from local
restaurants and I bought a large gift
certificate to use after the crisis is
over to help give them some cash now
that's not possible for everyone but if
it's possible for you please consider it
we're in this together and small
businesses need our help this is guy
Benson host of the guy Benson show
you've been listening to the FoxNews
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at FoxNews podcasts calm
and for up-to-the-minute news go to Fox
news.com
download and make it hammer time with
Bill Hemmer
trey gowdy welcome so if the Department
is going to start issuing making public
investigations about people that you
don't even have enough information to
charge that is a slippery slope
subscribe and listen now by going to fox
news podcasts dot-com love fox news
click the subscribe button to get more
of the news and opinion you trust and
click the Fox news rundown playlist for
the latest episodes